Speaker 1: In the midst of all of the hubbub
around Ron DeSantis announcing he's running
for president, Tim Scott announcing that he's
running, Donald Trump spending 24 to 48 hours
simply going after Ron DeSantis.
Everybody forgot about Nikki Haley.
Nikki Haley, the former governor of South
Carolina, is also running for the Republican
nomination.
She is getting absolutely no attention.
She's desperate for relevance.
So what does she do?
Yesterday, she goes out and let me go completely
anti-transgender.
Why not?
This seems to be playing well among some now.
She's not wrong.
The biggest applause lines for the last couple
of years at right wing events, including CPAC
and others, have been when speakers make fun
of or go after LGBT people, it's a resurgence
of that in the Republican Party.
So here is Nikki Haley figuring out, I guess,
how to get some attention.
Maybe people will choose her because she's
going to come out against trans people in
a disgusting way.
Here is what she had to say at Politics and
Eggs in New Hampshire.
Speaker 3: We've got biological boys playing
in girls sports.
It is the women's issue of our time.
Where is everyone?
Right.
My daughter ran track in high school.
Did she?
I wouldn't even know how to have that conversation
with her.
How do we get our girls comfortable with biological
boys in their locker room?
It's not okay.
Everybody know about Dylan Mulvaney.
Bud Light, right?
Right.
Make no mistake.
That is a guy dressed up like a girl.
Mm hmm.
Making fun of women.
Women don't act like that.
Get everybody wondering why a third of our
teenage girls seriously contemplated suicide
last year.
What are we doing to them?
We're supposed to be growing strong girls,
confident girls, not ones being made fun of.
Speaker 1: Right.
So one of the reasons that's actually evidence
base for the increase in suicidal ideation
among particularly teen girls, but teens in
general is unrestricted.
Access to social media seems to be extremely
damaging in many different ways.
Cal Newport has a recent podcast episode on
this issue that I highly recommend people
listen to.
But the idea among the anti-trans activists
that quote, keeping men out of women's sports,
that's how they call it.
We've got to keep men out of women's sports.
They pretend that it's a feminist issue, a
women's issue.
The claim that banning trans women from sports
is a feminist issue number one ignores the
history and diversity of actual feminism.
Feminism.
Feminism isn't this monolithic movement.
It's a compilation or combination of different
perspectives and goals that aim to achieve
what different people see as gender equality
and justice.
And there are many feminists who support trans
rights and inclusion, and they see trans women
as allies in a struggle against whatever it
is that they believe is the most important
thing to struggle against.
And so part of the feminist movement argues
that when you exclude trans women from women's
spaces and activities, you're actually reinforcing
the very harmful stereotypes that feminism
has sought to undo.
But it's okay to acknowledge that the so-called
look, let's not let's call it trans women
and women's sports, too, to try to put a less
offensive way to describe it.
That is a difficult issue for some sports
in which physical advantage comes from muscle
mass.
Weightlifting would be one example.
And I am the first to tell you that although
trans women and women's sports is an issue
that is a slice of a slice of a slice, right?
You've got like all political issues, issues
related to gender within issues related to
gender, issues that are under the trans category,
under trans, you have all sorts of different
issues, bathrooms and the within that you've
got sports.
And then a subsection of that would be sports
in which muscle mass confers a definitive
advantage.
So we're understanding the scope, right?
This is not the biggest issue.
There are different opinions about how it
should be handled.
Some say so.
You know, 31 states have gone the way of banning
biological male individuals from women's sports
in some capacity.
That's one approach some are taking.
It's been done in 31 states as of about a
year and a half ago.
The number may be slightly different.
Now.
That's one view.
Another approach is you let transwomen biological
males.
Different people use different terms for this.
You allow those individuals to compete in
women's sports if they meet certain criteria,
such as undergoing hormone suppression therapy
for a certain period of time.
As signed off on by a medical professional,
the NCAA has gone in that direction for some
sports in some cases.
Another idea is for the sports in which muscle
mass confers a definitive advantage.
You create a separate category for trans athletes
who don't fit into the other binary categories.
There are many who say that actually is going
to further stigma.
That's the last thing we need.
The point is there is a conversation to be
had about trans women, specifically in the
sports where muscle mass is really important.
Nikki Haley talking about a guy named Dylan
Mulvaney, who's with Bud Light.
Sponsorship is just disgusting, pandering
to the anti-trans crowd.
But nobody's paying attention to Nikki Haley,
and her campaign was dead on arrival.
So she's struggling for relevance